l'arboretum des bars compte neuf mille
spécimens représentant 2500 espèces
différentes en majorité ces arbres ont
plutôt bien résisté à la chaleur et à la
sécheresse
mais deux à trois cents d'entre eux
présentent quand même des signes de
faiblesse comme ce faux de verzy une
espèce de être très rare il a perdu ses
feuilles
dès le début de la canicule dès les
premiers coups de sécheresse s'est il
est assez coutumier du fait c'est pas
les déjà en 2003 elle est complètement
perdue ces feuilles et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il a eu le réflexe
de vraiment de tout les perdre on s'est
aperçu toujours pareil ensuite à 2003
que tous les arbres feuillus qui avait
gardé quelques feuilles sur le sur le
sur leur sim sur leurs rameaux avait
séché plus ou moins l'année dernière à
la même période il était encore couverts
de feuilles qui n'avait perdu qu'au mois
d'octobre
ça ne signifie pas pour autant qu'ils ne
s'en remettra pas il faudra attendre
quelques mois voire quelques années pour
savoir si la sécheresse et la canicule
long durablement affaibli mais à l'heure
actuelle celle de 2015 semble moins
violente que celle de 2003 en 2003 on
avait déjà on a eu tous nos tuyaux à
thoune au cyprès qui avait séché mais
brûler complètement là on soit la partie
conifères on a très peu de conifères
sécher plus tôt - c'était pas aussi
général en 2003 tous les tuyères a perdu
leur tête qu'un à 90 pour renault qui ya
là on voit ils sont tous tous vers
peut-être ils réagiront mal l'année
prochaine et au niveau des feux us et
c'est beaucoup moins en 2003 sur la
boîte hommes il y avait à peu près 1500
plants qui avait eu des qui a été
touchée par la canicule
au-delà du cas de l'arboretum les
scientifiques de lit est restée à qui
observe au quotidien l'évolution de la
forêt n'ont pas constaté de dégâts
importants cette année
le principal impact qu'on peut
observez et principalement sur les
aspects de croissance ont fait des
relevés de croissance intra nuel
plusieurs fois dans l'année et on peut
observer que certains individus pas tous
et en fonction des orages localisés
peuvent afficher des retraits de
croissance c'est à dire que l'arbre
arrête de pousser en règle générale un
arbre pousse l'été pendant la saison de
végétation est là actuellement la
croissance des arbres est plus faible
que ce qu'on pourrait attendre par
rapport aux années habituels comme chez
les humains seuls les spécimens les plus
fragiles succombent à la canicule
un gros coup de chaud peut les empêcher
de résister aux attaques de champignons
qui deviennent alors mortels